yes well I don't think so no
ok well we remember later
so ok big kisses to ba here I
was just waiting for you for the visit of the
big shop
so welcome to roland garros 2021
we are at the bottom of the court philippe chatrier
like you  can see the magnificent
courtyard which was inaugurated last year
and the esplanade of the musketeers and to
go and meet the shop we go down on
do me so you see in cannes we go
up the steps but if we go down them
to get to my favorite place  i
think the wall of roland garros posters is so beautiful
so it's been going on for 40 years it's a
bit of a ritual it's every year there is
an artist who wins a competition
for the right to have his poster which
will be  the daughter of roland garros all
more beautiful than the other
I think my favorite is that of
goods from borges to post some at home and
I am quite proud of one thing that of
my year of birth 1990 it  is the
first time  it was a woman
on life no more proud so hello
non-knowledge magistrate says thank you very much
thank you
we will start with the area is not
playing right there at the entrance and the
pickup the big ones for a masseur
it's true  me who does that and what are
you doing there why aren't you on the
course jeans well with the eternal rebel
play the balls played so all that
is balls played we see that they
are a little worn  our that they were
played they were played during the
matches and they sell them so ok but
it's too good an idea memories 2020
2021 so what I see well thank you
very much for this more explanations I
'll let you go back  run that to him we're going to
continue with the candor zone down there
wes herrett ropes when to buy
the ba yeah I'm going to have seen it well well
there it's the wilson boutique zone and
the grandet zone I just had the  bar
yeah what's going on at the same time
tell me you're waiting 23 24 jordi why
tomorrow morning t  u tell them you picanto
even on the other hand I'm going to be there to look for
a slope of nothing here so here the
corner zone it's the first time that
it's visible for the public so it's
great because
here we are in the  lair of roland garros
behind the scenes of what is done twenty
quarter of an hour permanently eleven different countries
is it someone to take the
racket of harold shirt
please him to give now
it  is the 23 24 and if you have a
corner available who can give us a
little explanation for my test it's
available you can talk to my guest to
talk a little about the tension of the string
all that yeah 23 24 and the tension does
not depend  a lot of factors
the operation if it's hot world if
it's cold in December
23 24 that's without the art it's a bit
there simply the girls are lower
higher a wishful thinking yeah yeah
it  is true it is logical that thank you
very much salute good luck we will
continue with the mythical
then I  I have some small numbers
on the corners it's I think the
record is 450 racquets strung in one
day which is a huge crime and on
average they take 19 minutes to
keep them so I don't know if you've
already granted  but it's still
record time so here is the shop its
balls hanging frankly I love it
it's no
and then the shop is divided into two
parts there is the bulagrie times romero
right there and there the the collab part
lacoste and  roland garros so we're gonna
start with the roland garros crisis and
my favorite place
all the kids clothes too
cute i'm talking about that we were doing that
guess it's gonna realize it's gonna be my
brother what are you doing
listen thank you hello and fans and friends
i  surprises me it's too cute me not the
dress but it's too cute also
one after I don't see myself with the top
but the roma is too cute years
you can't go wrong follow me believe me
I think it will be fine  well
I'm here for you  isse was going shopping to make
her list
so we go on with the wall of
towels
it's
a ritual a bit every year there's a
towel for men towel
for women and we exchange them to
try to have the whole collection
two years ago  extra napkins for the
mighty sean and for the final so that
's 4 napkins ever and there I'm
telling me something that's it I've
already seen but it's not
this year's one we're actually talking about
this  year we learn offers a range
of towels on cycle and with the
services of last year on cycle
and I know recycled but I did not
know how to recycle cycling and say that we
took last year's towels
yeah  and we transformed them into bags and
pouches okay it's good it's
ingenious
bravo lanta to waste like that either
it will be easy for the canton it must
be admitted it's doing it's a game of step
for the environment it's true bravo
very good idea
m  yes I wanted to work goodbye so there
you go then so after the wall of
towels
we have the wall of t-shirts right here
[Music]
worrying fact
it was pulling me a fabrice
fabrice it's ok to know everything
about
me I know access to breakage
what about the 50 years of
collaboration with roland garros this
year the brand 50 years of collaboration
when the brand is older
than that still the brand a few months
so for me for your 50 years was no
longer i like that  the collaboration la
corse roland garros
exactly and you are going to do
something to mark the
occasion so precisely this occasion we are lucky
to be able to have fun with polo shirts
with specificity moreover on this
occasion
fabrice birthday present ahead
are  used to it for your life you are
mentally magnificent there and therefore everything
falls from people that is not the
silhouette of rené lacoste silva what
i am telling you thank you gambo thank you very much
for case management u  don't ten balls
and you like it or you want on the water on
the polo the traumatized person
thank you here you are spoiled good go I
leave you I'm going to take them my
invite to the village area where it's if
I  think he's moving I've lost
mine ok I say hello with his next
glasses
I'm putting it on of choice come on I'm not letting you
go say you've seen the new range at
argos performance
and fashion and sport they're strong enough in
Corsica  for its sports fashion it's there the
village corner I think you can
find glasses well
yes here there are gones is there
so I'll let you watch I'll come back I
'll come back to get you what I need I
have to continue life  in rain this chaos
so here it is the village corner of
which there are the brands jm weston aux
deux fils it's an electric bike but
no one not if it's also gold
arrive at the event corner so here
worth photo animations
virtual reality experience signing sessions
and that will change  every day therefore
impossible to go he
therefore maintains his law very well since he does
you shop that it is that it
would be showers that's why we bring it back
it's the magic powder of the court
philippe chatrier offers  on the parts
of a go we bring back sand from the holidays
and their hangars years we bring back the
magic powder exactly listen in any case we
are we are we are delighted to see you here
then especially to welcome all other
audiences from  future basically this year
to have a nice edition public knows
how much this year honor these themes
he is 16 years old mintsa so last year
here good it was miles on
center court and local ad elsewhere
this year will be a thousand  by
main courses so we will have the first
week in the whole stadium a little more
than 5000 people or me will be on the
second week with 13000 people
over a few days and for the
finals of the games because already the
semi-finals 5000 people only
there on the  for sure  the central court
on how many places on the
central court is fifteen thousand plagiarist of the
stadium
that's me it's not so bad I'm expecting
by the way I thought it was I
think it was 5000 the whole stadium
your time  and then listen in any case
that's it the stadium is your book
is brand new should take this opportunity
to thank all our partners all
the broadcasters the big
tennis family who allowed us to present to
our public a brand new stadium with
its canvas  magnificent we will have beautiful
evening sessions it's a first
this year for us
t and then here it is so it starts in a
very short time so here we are ready
I'm on the block
you give me that's so much by
waiting that they work all  the year
above you go and we have fun
all year for that so here we
are only waiting for you so come
and see us quickly but there are always people at
roland-garros which we are a fan
I appreciate  that even the people who follow
not tennis are roland garros wife
good i will leave you csas room so
there it is the corner of memories there are
always bugs key rings
notebooks hats bibs
posters game i am doing a little everything thank you
i  would eat you pastry chef who you know
that all summer directly on this
organ all the articles
then I'm going to recover I don't know
no big deal it's in mainland France
and also abroad
first of all you owe thank you very much
[Music  ]
and so there we arrive at the checkout area
to pay for our purchases and this year
there are three new features
the first is that we can
barely call on a flying salesman if we are ever
a little impatient which is
often  my case we can order on
the mobile application from 80
euros of purchase and there is the click and
collect for people who do not
want to leave lessons and miss it, in
fact a game and therefore come to look
It shopping here beating but I had
ordered a cap but yes I
thought it was my cap around 6:10 am
I had ordered a
personalized cap there is a stand to
personalize it too and servette and the
caps
so I did I did clay color
press  rich hip hop for roland
garros
thank you here we come to the end of the
visit
we come back to the walls of posters I
'm going to get my phone and I
'm going to make myself I'm going to make myself a
grandson because it's so
photogenic here  and thank you
for taking the tour with me I hope
you enjoyed it I hope
Roland Garros will be magnificent in 2021 see
you soon